think of smartwatches and while Samsung
is Sony may come to mind here at Basel
world the traditional typically hold the
roost but does it now cachito is one
SmartWatch trying to make a splash at
the world's biggest watch and jewelry
fair what makes it different
it's a SmartWatch that our direction was
to make a watch with an extra feature so
we want the connectivity part of the
watch to remain extremely discreet and
if you don't know that it's a connected
watch it looks like a normal watch
they're not the only ones capitalizing
on a growing trend either Google's just
announced Android wear a specially
designed operating system for wearable
devices it'll be used not only by phone
makers LG and Motorola but even
accessory maker fossil to unveil their
new smartwatches so should the
traditional brands be worried the
reality is that SmartWatch won't replace
Swiss watches it's a new segment it's
providing technology great features and
so on but it doesn't replace luxury
exclusivity and status with more brands
jumping on the SmartWatch bandwagon the
competition for wrist space is very much
on